today's topic so somebody sent me a
video in my inbox and I want to play it
for you Oh recently I talked about
summer Walker in her post about the HIV
thing and in the video I talked about
disclosure and anytime I talk about
disclosure the stigma jumps out
immediately I mean people don't
understand and don't get it so the
poster that just posted a screenshot of
someone you know saying that it's my
obligation it is my duty as an HIV
positive man to disclose my HIV status
it is not my job to disclose my HIV
status to anybody even for partners it
is both people job to talk about theirs
for health okay you cannot put it on the
person who is living with HIV to be the
one to say look around little HIV that
I'm on my stuff and then you don't tell
me anything and come to find out you
ain't [ __ ] so you cannot put the entire
for health responsibility on one person
you cannot make me be responsible for
yours twelve and I can't make you be
responsible for mice okay if we both
come into a consensual relationship and
we both don't discuss us well then
that's on us but you're not going to
make me take responsibility because I'm
the person that is HIV positive and
living with HIV I have to take
responsibilities for everything and not
to mention you might have some stuff
going on you have not been tested and
you don't know because you're not
getting tested regularly you don't know
what's going on with your body okay
homie homie homie homie you being HIV
positive then you know you're HIV
positive and you don't disclose that to
the other person and the other person is
HIV positive because the result of that
boo that's a crime that's a crime
reprimanding oh by law and so what it's
an actual crime because you're putting
this person's safety at risk basically
is this if you got some say so not to
the whole world
but the person with that's not even a
stigma azita or is you stupid you have
to say so
oh let me told you cannot see this one
and you guessed it you was right is your
argument a sense to that because if they
don't ask that you don't have the
responsibility to disclose ok take HIV
which stay life-altering deadly disease
in a lot of situations right it is a
very serious thing
mumu if you got the flu and you come
into work you don't tell people but with
HIV you're not gonna faint you're not
gonna do the HIV when I was when I seen
this video I was so shocked about what I
was hearing I had to take ten steps back
just to make sure that I wasn't missing
something from the picture be safe out
there because mother that's crazy that's
what it telling me be safe out there
because mom is crazy I can understand
that you're stigmatized and that people
will see was undesirable and they
quarantine you because of what you have
that's unfortunate and I do wish that
only one Lord what I want to mock anyone
who's going through that I understand
that that can be a very difficult thing
but your response to that negative input
is not to try to make other people be in
as much danger as you are in yourself do
you understand and then blame it on
yourselves right like oh it's on us no
it's on you you knew if you understand
that you're going through pain and
suffering as a result of what you're
experiencing with your disease why would
you want to potentially put other people
through that risk I mean you're talking
about disease that's passed on
generationally it is very difficult to
live with HIV and I'm not mocking you
because if I'm just saying if it is such
must why would you risk giving that to
other people or not having that
conversation I mean if these are people
that you want to potentially love and
have long-lasting relationships is it
makes sense to disclose information off
the top that may affect the potential
future of that relationship to me it's
bad for a relationship standard is bad
from a health standard it's bad for you
bad for the community it's bad for
yourself
because you know that you are infecting
other people like what you've just said
maybe one of the most toxic things I've
ever seen on the Internet
I've been online for a long time we're
comparing you did a real that has got to
be the dumbest did I've heard today I
gotta check myself because I think that
should just gave me cancer no I gave you
aids look I don't know what to tell you
Gus I saw this video and I was
dumbfounded and there's people like this
in our communities unfortunately there's
people like this who feel like their
problems everyone else should pay the
burden of them because they've been hurt
that's kind of destructive as behavior
is this it's like it's comparable it's
comparable though to a lesser degree so
people would see it on their significant
others don't tell the person who
cheating with that they have a
significant other yeah then when they
get called out they're like well you
didn't ask to tell you sir you're trash
a special kind of trash not all men but
you undetectable
I should be disclosing my HIV status
I should be telling them
so anyways we want to just do this topic
because we want to bring light to the
fact that there are predators like this
man here and he is a predator that's a
predator yeah when you could potentially
you harm someone and you don't faint in
your pillar that's absolutely what is
very disappointing you know especially
you having a platform and being someone
who's HIV positive I think there's a lot
of positive ways that you can affect the
community in that regards and for you to
say such toxic stuff it blows my mind
blows my mind so anyways that's pretty
much all I got
not that that so I know I told you when
I saw that video I'm like we have to
understand that people who have HIV may
be taking medication that completely
100% suppresses it to the point that
it's even undetectable in your DNA and I
understand that if you were that
scientifically speaking the odds of you
transmitting it are pretty much
non-existent that being said you still
have the obligation to tell your partner
anyone you were sleeping with because it
would matter to them I don't know if
it's a crime still in those
circumstances and it's not a crime
everywhere so it's limited to a couple
states yeah at the end of the day what's
important to the other person if you
know something that you're holding it is
important to the person before y'all
sleep together you should tell them you
should because it's it's the empathetic
thing to do and I don't know why you
would be engaging in any kind of special
encounter with somebody if you're not
going to have that limited amount of
empathy well if you have herpes right
you got it but you not flair enough you
should still tell the other person
because they should be able to make that
choice for themselves you should not rob
them of the information they need to
make the choices that they want to make
more risk was this sort of risk it's
almost non-existent but it's still
something you should tell them right if
let's say your wife is in a different
country and there's no risk of us
getting caught right if we sleep if we
have an affair you should tell me that
you have a wife still even if there's no
risk you should tell me so that I can
make that decision for myself you
understand whatever preconceived notion
society has that may be unfair towards
you I get it but it's still your
obligation to tell people because you
know it's important to them see with a
trans person
there is no psychological physical risk
there's nothing but you should still
tell people if you are trans because you
know it wouldn't matter to who were mad
at a person yeah all right I'm Ethiopian
if somebody said I don't see with
Ethiopians I always sleep with some
morons all right if she thought I was to
mine I would tell her I'm easy opium
does that void consent what do you mean
I don't know she consented to sleep with
a Somalian and now you said okay
I wouldn't go that far no no no
what all this to say you know all this
to say people I get it a lot of people
have stigmas and negative impressions
about some things and a lot of it's
unfair that being said be safe out there
be smart before word any - be empathetic
even if it's to your own detriment
meaning like you lose out on somebody
trust me it's much better for everybody
forced honest what do you advise you
give to people or what I'm numb it
anything else even helmets won't help
against certain stuff like herpes yeah
yeah if you're wearing a helmet you
still catch the herpes and someone with
herpes I hope they would tell somebody
they're about to sleep with that they
have that yeah yeah you know again this
is not to say you guys are shameful or
you're bad if you got those things we
understand [ __ ] happens but sharing is
Gary not the disease
[Music]
Hey